Hello大家好,我是Vicky
今天我想跟大家分享一个连庄家都在偷偷用的秘密指标
也是我交易系统中比较喜欢用的指标
OPV 能量桥指标
大家有没有遇到过这样的情况
价格刚刚突破关键位
你信心满满的冲进去
结果它马上回调,把你的止损打爆
那种感觉就像你的暗恋对象给你发了一条信息
那信息的内容就是
我们还是做朋友吧
简直扎心到无法呼吸啊
别担心
今天Vicky用5分钟教会大家如何用OBV能量潮指标
来帮助我们判断真假突破
抓住暴涨的行情
学会一眼看穿渣男渣女的那些小心思
准备好了吗
Let's go
在交易技术分析中主要有四大要素
量 价 时 空
也就是交易量
价格
周期
空间
支撑阻力位
量与价能让我们知道
当前的动能如何
而时跟空呢
则来帮助我们评估
这个行情要走到哪里
要走多久
我记得我刚刚做交易的时候
整天被这个行情耍得团团转
一看到价格疯涨啊
就马上立刻就进去
结果发现
哎
被套在山顶
啊
一看到价格暴跌哎呀心想着忍痛割爱吧赶紧割肉吧还能少亏一点然后呢他又蹭蹭的反弹后来我才发现是我一直没有搞懂量跟价格的关系
而OBV呢
正好是从交易量的角度切入
把量价关系数字化
可视化
让我们更能直观的判断趋势
自从学会运用这个OBV
再结合其他的指标
我的这个交易系统变得完善了很多
亏钱的次数呢
也明显的减少了
话不多说我们直接进入干货吧
我们来看一下什么是OBV
OBV全称Umbalanced Volume
中文叫做能量超纸表
它是一个基于成交量变化
用来识别市场动能的技术分析指标
这是OBV的计算公式
当前收盘价高于前一日的收盘价
那就用先前的OBV加上当前的成交量
等于当前的OBV
如果当前的收盘价低于前一日的收盘价
就用先前的OBV减去当前成交量
等于当前的OBV
如果当当前的收盘价
等于前一日的收盘价
那OBV是不变的
先前的OBV等于当前的OBV
然后将这些累积量相加或相减
就能得到OBV取现
我会把更详细的计算公式与代码
放在下方的视频说明栏中
感兴趣的朋友可以研究下哦
简单来说
OBV的核心作用就是量在先
价债后
当OBV持续上升
往往意味着资金源源不断的流入那趋势动能就增加当OBv下降则意味着卖盘力量加大或者是主力资金在撤离接下来我们就直接进入图表当中
看看这个指标如何使用
我们打开TradingView
在搜索栏这边搜索obv
点击obv能量潮
添加完毕之后
我们可以看到有一根线
可以看到obv的走势
跟k线的走势是差不多一致的
接下来我们来看看如何使用obv指标
当OBV上升
那价格也上升
这说明这是一个非常健康的上涨趋势
为了让我们更直观的看到
多空OBV曲线的变化
大家可以添加
OBVOSC OBV Oscillator
这个可以更清晰的看到
多空OBV交易量曲线的变化
那我们就删掉默认的OBV
用这个更加直观的曲线来演示操作
OBV的两大实战技巧
第一个技巧
用OBV来识别趋势反转
这个也是Vicky我特别喜欢用的一招
当价格它创新高
但是OBV没有跟上
这就是所谓的背离状态
那背离状态呢
就意味着趋势可能要反转了
例如这里的价格在上涨
但是呢
OBV没有同步
这个时候如果大家手头上有单
那就要考虑部分止盈
一定要拉好止损线
结合其他的指标
比如我们上次讲的ADS指标
看是否要反手开空
相反的
当这个价格一直在创新低
但是OBV并没有创新低这就意味着当前的空军的力量在不断的减弱如果手头上有空单那就要考虑部分止盈拉好止损线如果这个时候ATX在不断的增强
这个时候可以考虑反手开多
技巧二
确定突破信号
当价格突破关键的阻力位的时候
同时OBV也同步上升
这就是真突破啦
例如在这里价格突破了前高
OBV也随着放量上升
那结果就是这个价格持续的暴涨
再结合ADX
如果这个时候ADX也增加
则说明趋势越来越强劲
接下来我用两个实际的案例
来说明OBV在实战交易中的应用
在这张图表中
我们可以看到价格还在横盘当中
但是OBV在稳步的攀升
这就暗示着有资金在提前布局
那多头的力量逐渐是在增强的
我们可以选择在这个时候开多
并把止损设置在关键的支撑位
我们来看另一个例子
价格看似好像在往上突破
但是OBV的曲线却开始走弱
这往往意味着行情可能要开始反转了
就要考虑部分止盈
拉好止损线
配合其他的交易指标
考虑要不要开反方向的单子
OBV是我用的
所有的指标当中
比较喜欢用的指标
也是我交易系统中特别重要的指标
好了
那今天的内容就到这里了
希望大家喜欢
如果你觉得今天的内容
对你有帮助的话
别忘了留言告诉我
我是Vicky
我们下期见
拜拜